they saw the end of the world I could  feel all this death Jean it was just a  dream in the forest  I've been called many things over many  lifetimes trying to  raaah krishna yahweh ever since the  world found out about mutants there have  been secret societies who see them as  some kind of second coming or sign of  God they believe that tens of thousands  of years ago ancient being was born the  world's first mutant you are all my  children and they lost  because you follow blind leaders  man now I'm here for you  wherever this being was he always had 4  followers he would imbue with power like  the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse got  that one from the Bible more the bible  got it from him what is it oh god he can  control all of us  the world needs the x-men that's why I'm  here to fight not all of us can control  our powers  then don't this is war  everything they feel  will fall and from the ashes of their  world will build a better one  I've never felt power like this before